determine the six trigonometric ratios
for angle a in the right triangle below
so this right over here is angle a it's
at vertex a and to help me remember the
definitions of the trig ratios and these
are human constructed definitions that
have ended up being very very useful for
analyzing a whole series of things in
the world but to help me remember them I
use the word sohcahtoa so let me write
that down
so so so
CUH so Toa sometimes you can think oh
there's one word but it's really the
three parts that define at least three
of the trig functions for you and then
we can get the other three by looking at
the first three so Soh tells us that
sine of an angle in this case it's sine
of a so sine of a is equal to the
opposite opposite that's the O over the
hypotenuse opposite over the hypotenuse
well in this context what is the
opposite side to angle a well we go
across the triangle it opens up onto
side BC it has length 12 so that is the
opposite side so this is going to be
equal to 12 and what's the hypotenuse
well the hypotenuse is the longest side
of the triangle it's opposite the
90-degree angle and so we go opposite
the 90-degree angle longest side aside a
B it has length 13 so this right over
here is the hypotenuse so the sine of a
is 12 13 now let's go to cut cod defines
cosign for us it tells us that cosine of
an angle in this case cosine of a is
equal to the adjacent side the adjacent
side to the angle over the hypotenuse
over the hypotenuse so what's the
adjacent side to angle a well if we look
at angle a there's two sides that are
next to it one of them is the hypotenuse
the other one has length five the
adjacent one is side C a so it's five
and what is the hypotenuse well we've
already figured that out the hypotenuse
right over here it's opposite the 90
angle it's the longest side of the right
triangle it has length 13 so the cosine
of a is 513 and let me label this this
right over here is the adjacent side and
this is all specific to angle a the
hypotenuse would be the same regardless
of what angle you pick but the opposite
and the adjacent is dependent on the
angle that we choose in the right
triangle now let's go to Toa Toa defines
tangent force it tells us that the
tangent the tangent of an angle is equal
to the opposite equal to the opposite
side over the adjacent side so given
this definition what is the tangent of a
well the opposite side we already
figured out has length 12 as length 12
and the adjacent side we already figured
out has length 5 so the tangent of a
which is opposite over adjacent is 12
fifths now we'll go to the other three
trig ratios which you could think of as
the reciprocals of these right over here
but I'll define it so first you have
cosecant and cosecant it's always a
little bit unintuitive why cosecant is
the reciprocal of sine of a even though
it starts with a KO like cosine but
cosecant deserves typical of the sine of
a so sine of a is opposite over
hypotenuse cosecant of a is hypotenuse
over opposite and so what's the
hypotenuse over the opposite well the
hypotenuse is 13 and the opposite side
is 12 I notice 13 12 is a reciprocal of
12 13 now secant of a it's the
reciprocal so instead of being adjacent
over hypotenuse which we got from the
cut part of sohcahtoa its hypotenuse its
hypotenuse over adjacent so what is the
secant of a well the hypotenuse we've
figured out multiple times already is 13
and what is the adjacent side it's five
so it's 13 fifths which is once again
the reciprocal of the cosine of a 513
finally let's get the cotangent and the
cotangent is the reciprocal of tangent
of a instead of being opposite over
adjacent it is adjacent over opposite so
what is the code
tangent of a well we figured out the
adjacent side multiple times for angle
eighths length five and the opposite
side to angle a is 12 so it's five
twelfths which is once again the
reciprocal of the tangent of a which is
12 fifths